I mean you have a lot of jobs like on
like three different continents but I
feel like you do a really good job of
that I connected people I'm being real
with the people like whatever show
you're on your your very real with them
you're very honest you're supportive and
like a cool way like I'm really good at
that
I've got a job on three different
continents No yeah I'm doing three
different shows right now judging and
being on a panel you know what that's
like a minute I work with Simon I do X
Factor with him I do Australia's Got
Talent yeah that's been fun the
Australian accent is just it's good
times guys it's sex
it's hates hates of fun I said and then
I'll go the masked singer here so it's
crazy I think I did 10 15 hour flights
in in less than three weeks just just
now I just flew in are you awake like
what is it like a lot of caffeine
involved actually I love a little
tequila but actually I can't do that
with this schedule it's crazy I've been
I've been trying to sleep on the plane
as much as I can because normally I rest
and then I go straight set on the plane
I don't I actually like it I find it
it's like a little date with myself okay
that and then when I land I always go
straight to a workout because I have to
sweat it out and I learned a new word
I'd like to share with you all I want I
wish I did back I don't know I don't
want to I go to like eat pie
[Laughter]
[Applause]
work out so I can eat that pie locally
for seven but I learned a new word in
Australia
you guys ready so this is what's keeping
me motivated what I learned uh sue what
does anyone know what a Sulha is a Sulha
mmm if you don't have a sila you're not
working hard enough a survivor is a
sweaty up a lip alert Oh a sweaty upper
lip alert so you got a leg work so hard
you get that little I call that the
Whitney I feel like Whitney always had
that right here you like I work so hard
for she working on you she was working
part of it yeah y'all are working out
I'm gonna go for the lips wet the dough
for the Sula hey your accents really
good by the way
it's rubbish that was really good we
actually grew up well I'm from the south
as well Sam yo E I was born in Hawaii
but I grew up in Kentucky do you think
it's crazy no ok you grew up in the
south and maybe for more humble
beginnings and obviously now like do you
think it's crazy of like my husband I
talk about this all the time with my
life like in our life or like wow we
came from like nothing and like you know
do you think about that like yeah I come
from real humble beginning me too I
think when I was 6 years old though is
when I heard a voice that changed my
life forever and that was Whitney oh and
I heard the song the greatest love of
all such an epic song the lyrics are so
prevalent still today right I love
that's literally I love hearing now what
were your kind of beginnings you better
have been humble Toni
[Applause]
my favorite thing to do is I go to a
mall I my first no but I ever when I
moved to New York my first show with
Shakespeare in the parking lot in the
East Village
I'm not kidding we did Taming of the
Shrew in the parking lot in the East
Village and I racked it oh no we do
Shakespeare next village folks it's in
the mid-90s to top that Nicole in my
club my first studio is my closet
because all the acoustics all the
clothes I've also watched compilation
videos of your judging on YouTube okay
yeah oh yeah I've seen you cry too
singers and I'm I love it there's this
one guy I won't get it I'm gonna stop no
that one guy if you get a support he had
actually a grey suit like this but it
was like you it's That moment when they
hit the note and you go huh
and that and you and I you could always
tell what it's moving cuz you're always
starting to cry and I was telling Kelly
I love watching those compilations but I
can't understand how you guys reject I
mean I would be the Paula Abdul of the
panel okay I'd be like in the beginning
I used to be just so precious just so -
sure sure
I just could never say no I'm your
southern came out there now Tony after
all these years - no cut - I'm just like
next don't waste my
[Laughter]
hang it with Simon let me help you out
alright yeah you can relish in that
that's delicious is yummy in your
bedroom okay
no but know is that I'm a maggot like I
pride myself mostly in mentoring so I'm
all talk now but I always give construct
and you're not helping them by just
biessing them you're not but I also give
constructive criticism they never show
it after in the edits but I usually give
them a long list of like listen I need
you to work because I need you to stop
anywhere if you ever want to get
anywhere if you ever want to get
anywhere in life it's gonna take work
you guys must feel that empath of like
if everybody's coming on that stage so
nervous
is it hard not to take on that anxiety
oh I mine isn't like about like nervous
of it for them like you know auditioning
mine is if they get a no it's the first
season I cried like all the time because
I was just so like and they're like you
need to harden up a bit because and
you're making it seem worse than it is
because it's not a no forever it's
enough for now and that was really I
started out like that my first couple
years no I'm like you're wasting my time
and I sound like that was so nice I'm
not kidding my family like my mom and
sisters especially are obsessed like my
sister was obsessed with the masked
singer so we are very much looking
forward to it
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this